Ukraine has come under heavy fire again
missiles have struck cities across the
country including the capital Kiev at
least 10 people have been killed
Russia's president said their strikes
are in response to an attack on a key
bridge between Russia and the annexed
Crimean Peninsula Ukraine's president
has accused Russia of wanting to quote
wipe us from the face of the Earth and
as warning citizens to seek shelter
multiple blasts Rock Central Kiev during
morning Rush Hour
civilian targets were struck in The
Barrage of strikes the first to hit the
capital in months
in the morning we were woken up with
this greeting from our neighbors in
Russia you see all this here and across
the entire city Putin
these are synonyms we hope for our
Victory
this is a tragedy not just for civilians
who are dying but also for the military
or for the sake of a whim of one idiot
who leads Russia
Ukraine's president accused Russia of
trying to wipe his Nation from the face
of the Earth
speaking on the streets of Kiev he said
the strikes were time to inflict maximum
damage
they want to create panic and Chaos they
want to destroy our Energy System the
second target is people they
deliberately chose such a time and such
Targets in order to cause as much harm
as possible but we are ukrainians we
help each other we believe in ourselves
we will restore everything that was
destroyed several other cities far from
the front lines were also rocked by
explosions
zelenski says energy infrastructure
across the country was targeted
in the western city of leviv electricity
and hot water were cut by the blasts
people across Ukraine are now taking
shelter as they brace for a potential
new phase in Russia's War
correspondent is in Keith and I asked
her what she witnessed there this
morning
I was basically starting my day it's a
really sunny October Monday morning when
I heard these explosions first I didn't
know whether actually it's an explosion
because it sounded like something else
but certainly the second and the third
one was a huge bank so what we did uh
going to the scene as soon as we could
and what we found there was a lot of
debris uh cars that were black because
of the uh shelling that happened there a
huge crater in the middle of this street
it's a road by the way one of the main
roads here that people use when they go
to work actually it's one of those roads
that we have been frequently using as
well in the past so being there we were
shocked ourselves seeing this seeing uh
all the emergency units trying to come
through what they see there trying to
help people and as we are there at the
scenery and we are trying to talk to our
Witnesses that's where more explosions
happen so we also had to leave the scene
and look for shelter right now we're
able to actually report again on camera
and talk to you on camera again because
the Airaid siren that was on for hours
is off does it mean that everything is
calm and safe certainly not in fact the
Ukrainian officials are all warning
people to stay in those shelters as long
as possible today because nobody really
knows how this day is going to unfold
now what's known about these attacks
what is known so far according to
Ukrainian information that more than 80
missile strikes hit towns across Ukraine
and about half of them apparently have
been intercepted but you're talking here
about numbers and if you look at the
side especially where we are this
morning really just a block away from we
are staying in this hotel you see again
this fear this shock and also this panic
in the eyes of people something that I
remember from the beginning of the war
When We Were Here on February 24th more
almost like a Deja Vu of people packed
up with yoga mats trying to go to a
nearby shelter which is the Metro
station for most of the people as far as
the numbers are concerned there's
conflicting information just how many
casualties they are when it comes to QFC
the latest that we have heard about five
people who have been killed and at least
15 injured but it's expected that this
number is going to be corrected upwards
simply by looking at the destruction
there at that main road and and what is
to come as a result when it comes to the
number of injured people and as I say
this is only Kiev City there have been
explosions in many parts of Ukraine
today
have you heard anything from the other
parts of Ukraine the other cities that
have been hit
actually we've been just on the phone
with our sources in Libya which is in
the center of Ukraine where live is on
the western part of Ukraine they are
describing they have no running water no
electricity no access to Internet and
this actually reflects what Ukraine's
president zelenski has been saying that
one target is civilians as an act of
terrorism really and another Target is
critical infrastructure Energy Systems
basically everything that can turn
people into chaos and panic not knowing
what to do and this is all Happening by
the way at the time gerhardt when a lot
of people are coming back to Ukraine in
fact I've been traveling on this
overnight train from Poland to Ukraine
last night and there were so many
mothers with the children longing to go
back to Kiev City and other parts of
Ukraine because they simply missed their
home so all of this is happening at a
time where especially people who live in
bigger cities far away from the front
lines felt quite safe and and according
to the government this is exactly what
now Russia is trying to turn this
feeling and rather say that Russia is
under control of how this war is going
to develop and people are concerned it's
going to be worse
reporting from Keith thank you funny
Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
has spoken with the leaders of Germany
and France in the wake of the attacks
and urged them to increase pressure on
Russia he's also issued a video
statement in former ukrainians of the
extent of the strikes yes his statement
in full
this morning is tough we are dealing
with terrorists dozens of missiles
Iranian shahides they have two Targets
energy facilities throughout the country
key region and kemenelski Lev and
denipro Venezia Ivano francives region
Sumi region khaki region zitama region
kirovad region the site of the country
they want panic and Chaos they want to
destroy our Energy System they are
incorrigible the second target is people
the time when the targets were
especially chosen to cause as much
damage as possible but we are ukrainians
we will help each other we believe in
ourselves we will restore everything
that's destroyed there may be temporary
power outings now but there will never
be an outage of our confidence our
confidence is Victory why such strikes
exactly the enemy wants us to be afraid
wants to make people run but we can only
run forward and we demonstrate this on
the battlefield it will continue to be
so Rescuers are working now our air
defense system is working 38 aerial
targets have already been shot down
please stay in shelters today thanks to
the help of our military everything will
be fine and always remember Ukraine
existed before this enemy appeared and
Ukraine will exist after it glory to
Ukraine
witnessed several of the airstrikes this
morning in Keith and earlier she told me
what that was like
so I woke up just 10 minutes before the
first rocket
um hit the the KFC City Center because I
leave 10 minutes from the city center
and it was around eight something a.m
when I heard the whistle and then the
explosion now uh how did you react when
when the air Sirens went off this
morning did you immediately go in and
take shelter
I went to the shelter after I heard like
some uh explosions already because I
didn't I hear the the first the first
alert and maybe because it's been I
think three or four months since the
last shelling in Kiev we as Citizens
became a big class uh you know attentive
to the aerate Awards that's why I when I
heard the explosion itself and the
whistle of the rocket then I went to the
shelter
uh president zielinski said that the
airstrikes also had vital infrastructure
including power stations
um did it hit anything next uh to you or
is this is it already palpable that
infrastructure was hit
yeah I'll leave just three or four
minutes walk from the uh Power Plant and
um when I was in the shelter for about
one hour and a half it was relatively
quiet to me then I decided to go to my
bedroom to take some warm clothes
because it was really cold and then I
heard this super big explosion and that
was the explosion when the Russians they
hit the thermal power plant and also the
business center which is just 200 meters
from my house so both of them were hit
and the hull as Street was in a smoke
and then uh even my ears were really
grinning and I ran immediately to the
shelter and it was really frightening to
me
tell us about the mood in the city now
that the the war who as you mentioned
has been absent from a Kiev in a way but
now it's come back with a vengeance not
only to clear but to other places as
well but when you for example when you
were in the shelter this morning you've
been with other people there what's
what's the mood like right now in Kiev
Paul really they're not scared in a way
because they really believe that
um it won't change our strategy and
Ukraine will win in any way uh we all
are heard our president who was
um actually talking to us this morning
and people in the shelters they started
singing Ukrainian songs and even you
know playing the piano uh when they had
some musical instruments so the mood is
not really depressive
um it's um it's not that case but of
course in Kiev we've been without active
shelling for quite a long time that's
why right now it was a very uh it was a
shock for everyone I think
the most key president Maria sericenko
speaking to us earlier about the missile
attacks there now key right routing is a
member of the Ukrainian Parliament and
the leader of the opposition voice party
and I asked her what message she thinks
Russia wanted to send with the fresh
strikes
the message is a despair
when the Crimean Bridge was destroyed
and it was illegally built military
object that was used to deliver
uh deliver rocket and supplies to
Russian army they decided to attack
Ukrainian infrastructure civilian
infrastructure and to kill ukrainians
whenever they are this is a message that
is intended to internal auditory in
Russia where Putin is saying that no
attack on Russia will go unpunished but
it also shows that there is nothing else
that he can do and for us in Ukraine we
only stay stronger and it only allows us
to say give us more weapons give us
protection so we can stop rushing
themselves give us an ability to defend
ourselves because you see what is going
on today Putin and Putin's rocket
attacked
children's playground is it like is is
something that even supposed to be
happening in 21st century and in eight
months in this war we have been begging
for our lives to close the sky or give
us the ability to close the sky and as
of right now the fact that we are still
unable to protect ourselves from the
attack from the ear is is just like a
Pity and shame and an ability for us to
to scream for help please give us the
Jets please give us an Air Force
protection please give us more weapons
so we can defend ourselves so we can
protect our lives lives of our children
that was the Ukrainian Member of
Parliament he wrote rudick speaking to
me earlier now Russia's action in
carrying out strikes against Ukrainian
civilian targets have been widely
condemned a spokesman for the European
Union called the attacks war crimes
the Russia is
opting for a tactics uh with aiming and
indiscriminately bombing the civilians
this is something which is against
International humanitarian law and this
indiscriminate targeting of civilians
amounts to a war crime
EU foreign policy Chief Joseph Burrell
said he was deeply shocked by Russia's
attacks on civilians in a tweet he said
such acts have no place in the 21st
century I condemn them in the strongest
possible terms and he promised
additional military support from the EU
is on its way
the Chinese foreign Ministry called for
de-escalation
we have taken note of the relevant
reports and we also hope that the
situation can de-escalate soon
UK foreign minister James cleverley
tweeted Russia's firing of missiles into
civilian areas of Ukraine is
unacceptable he said he had been in
touch with Ukraine's foreign minister to
pledge the UK's ongoing moral and
practical support to Ukraine
this is a demonstration of weakness by
Putin not strength cleverly wrote
now let's have a look at some of the
other developments related to the war in
Ukraine
Belarusian president Alexander
lukashenko has announced part of his
country's Armed Forces will be forming a
joint unit with the Russian army the
kushenka says he and Russia's Vladimir
Putin had agreed to the move at a recent
Summit in Saint Petersburg he claims to
have received intelligence suggesting
Ukraine was planning to attack
Belarusian territory foreign
and the prime minister of Estonia kaya
kalas say they backed the formation of
an international Court to investigate
war crimes committed in Ukraine from the
line is in the Baltic Nations Capital
City talent for his Summit on a digital
cooperation
Russia's President Vladimir Putin has
now confirmed what many had suspected
that the range of strikes against
Ukrainian cities are in fact retaliation
for an attack on the Kirch rail bridge
over the weekend the bridge between
Russia and the occupied Crimean
Peninsula was opened only four years ago
it was a flagship project for Moscow
picking up the scraps at the side of a
bridge that stood as a symbol of
moscow's illegal annexation of Crimea
Saturday's powerful blast caused a
strategic bridge to partially collapse
disrupting travel and what is the only
direct link between Russia and a Crimean
peninsula
a queue of cars stretched 22 kilometers
on Monday some passengers said they'd
been waiting for up to 12 hours
it's scary but we have to go home the
bridge is now open for transport but
only to Vehicles weighing less than 3.5
tons Vehicles wearing more will have to
Cross by ferry
Russian President Vladimir Putin has
blamed Ukrainian Secret Service agents
for the blast calling it a terrorist act
he has vowed to rebuild the bridge
a short time ago I spoke with military
analyst Franklin which he gave us his
assessment of Putin's reason for
unleashing these strikes at this point
in the war
the objectives of the Russian attack was
to attack to attack the morale of the
civilian population is clearly failing
and that is what Putin means he's trying
to attack the will of the uh defending
ukrainians to undercut their motivation
to fight further and in this as you
heard before they are bound to fail
why exactly do you think that that is so
what you heard from your previous two
interlocutors two reasons first of all
the resilience is second the anger but
from a military perspective we can also
look at history so every campaign that
was designed to attack civilian morale
so-called strategic bombing has failed
be that Germany in the second world war
be it Vietnam in the Vietnam Vietnam War
but Kosovo or Serbia I should say in the
cost in the Kosovo war and so forth the
one example sometimes raises Aleppo by
the way led by the same generals who are
leading this brutal War where some
success was achieved but of course there
they weren't fighting the uh masked
forces of an extremely capable military
power that have shown themselves capable
willing and able to defeat Russian
forces in the field repeatedly now what
do you think uh um Ukraine and its
allies should do now in response
well Kara there was talking about air
defenses and I think what we're going to
see over the next week or two is an
uptick in that particular military
capability and specifically I think what
the ukrainians will be looking at are
American Norwegian nay Sands now there
are some already on the way may be
deployed but more importantly Patriot
systems now the problem there is they're
going to need a while to train on those
but that will have where they deployed
and it will take some time they would
have the effect of being able to shoot
down the missiles today or most of them
that got through so I think that's what
we're going to be needing that's what
the West will be asked for we'll also be
asked for a no-fly zone consideration
will be given I suspect that they
refused
now the Russian attacks on critical
infrastructure are designed to inflict
serious pain on Ukrainian citizens
targeting their energy Supply heating
ahead of the winter what do you think
why do you think this strategy will
actually fail as you mentioned earlier
well because history history
demonstrates it where you know whether
it's the blitz spirit that we see today
in Ukrainian shelters where people are
singing the National Anthem or singing
national songs or keeping their spirits
up and combine that with the anger and
determination and grit of a country and
a people that's put up with brutal
aggression successfully for the last
eight months that's not something that's
going to be depleted by attacking
playgrounds universities or glass
Bridges and by the way failing to hit uh
to hit the latter I had to quickly with
a half a million pound Precision guided
bomb tells you something about the gang
that can't shoot straight that can't a
literally can't but without being
flippant about it to answer your
question directly what this does is
increase the resilience of a population
not reduce it
militariana that's Frank Edwards there
thank you Frank
now Germany's chance that Olaf Shields
spoke to Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski following the attacks Charles
spokesman said the chancellor told
zelinski Germany will do everything in
its power to mobilize additional Aid to
Ukraine and in particular to help
restore damaged civilian infrastructure
the Russian missile strikes have renewed
calls to speed up delivery of a German
air defense system requested by Ukraine
defense minister Christina lambrecht has
said Berlin would quickly deliver the
first of four Iris T Systems but they
have not yet been dispatched during a
visit to Lithuania at the weekend
lambrecht condemned Russian missile and
drawn attacks on the Ukrainian
population
now let's bring in uh German MP Robin
Wagner he's a member of the greens and
part of the German defense committee
Ukraine is asking once again for more
weapons Germany is once again promising
to deliver an air defense system but
Germany's made that promise not only in
June but also just eight days ago are we
talking about an additional one now
well actually concerning the air defense
systems we made the promise and we said
that it will take some time to deliver
it but what we definitely need to do is
react strongly on the attacks that we
are seeing now which are born out of
fear Vladimir Putin who is failing with
his criminal aggression against Ukraine
and we definitely need to support
Ukraine even stronger we need to take
leadership role in the European Union
and support Ukraine with more air
defense but also with more main better
tanks and armored personal carriers in
order to be able to liberate territory
you've been talking about for months and
months and months
um where's the hold up
uh well actually we have said that we
will deliver air defense and we said
that it will take some time but
definitely we need to increase the
efforts to deliver air defense but in
addition to that it's not only our
defense it's also ground support and we
we should take a leadership role I urge
to our government to take up the
leadership role in European Union in the
transatlantic community and make a step
in the community to deliver modern
Western tanks and more modern Western
weapons uh in total for Ukraine because
that is what is making a difference what
we see now is the action of of Putin's
Criminal Mind reacting to his failing
Warfare that he's doing he's failing
because of the support that we have done
and because of The Bravery of Ukraine
but we must not let him create his
Terror that he's trying to spread in
civilian population so we need to defend
population and help Ukraine Liberate the
territory because that is the only way
to stop war crimes now Russia also seems
to attack critical infrastructure uh
more often not only in Ukraine today we
hear about a so far unexplained power
outages on the Danish island of born
home there was a recent Act of sabotage
on the German Railway system still
unexplained uh just two weeks after
sabotage attacks on the North stream gas
pipeline does Germany does Europe have
to prepare for uh more acts like this
we are in a constant aggression of
totalitarian totalitarianism against
democracy that we are seeing here we
don't know yet the exact causes of what
is going on in bornholm of what was
happening with the German Railway um the
sabotage but what we know is that we had
political murder in Germany that we have
destabilization campaigns that we have
cyber attacks going on so it is a
constant attack that is going on here
and that is also something that we need
to take into our calculation when we
respond to Russian war of emulation
Ukraine we have to stop Russia in
Ukraine also for our own safety here in
Germany so what what is Germany
currently doing to to guarantee let's
say the safety of critical
infrastructure
well we are we are um working on on
plans how to um better uh support our
civilian uh critical infrastructure what
we have and that is a problem we had 16
years of leadership of our conservative
party here in Germany and we see that we
are not very good in um counter spinach
that we are not very good in protecting
the civilian infrastructure that we are
not very good in defending against cyber
attacks but we will have to improve on
that we have seen the reports on the um
you can see with the hashtag cyberclown
on Twitter we have we see all these
things we need to react on that because
we we have a Heritage of a very weak
defense in that that part and that is
something we we inherited from our
conservative party here after 16 years
thank you very much corbyn Wagner there
from the Green Party
thank you